اسمع تعليقك عميد الياس عن سحب الكتيبه
271 ا كتيبه الهندسه
القتاليه زين العابدين الغريب في الامر ان
الهندسه هي اخذت اكبر دور مهم في الاعتداء
او في الحرب على غزه ان كان في الشمال او
في الوسط او في الجنوب وحتى العناصر التي
قتلت يعني في عندما فجر المبنى ب 21 جندي
اسرائيلي في وسط القطاع اي كانوا من
الهندسه يعني اليوم الهندسه ال العمل
الاهم لها في هذه المنطقه لماذا
التجريف
الانفاق الفتوحات الانفاق وبالتالي تدمير
المباني وهي عمليه اصبحت ممنهجه ان تسحب
هذه الكتيبه هناك عده يعني هناك عده اسباب
قد يكون السبب اولا تكبد هذه الكتائب
الخسائر الكبيره خاصه وانها يعني حسب ما
نرى من فيديوهات كتائب القسام هناك دائما
استهداف للجرافات الدي 9 استهداف للهندسه
التي تعمل في المقدمه استهداف لقائد نائب
قائد الكتيبه 601 التابعه للواء 401 في
شمال القطاع ايضا هذه الاستهدافات وكانه
قد يكون هناك خسائر كبيره لابد من اخراجها
او سحبها كما سحبت بعض الالويه استعدادا
لما قال عنه نتنياهو انه
اعطى الجيش الاسرائيلي الامر بالاستعداد
لرفح وتسريب خبر من قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي
انه سيسمح لل النازحين والمهجرين من
بيوتهم من الغزاويين بالذهاب الى الشمال
قبل بدء العمليه وبدات مؤشرات عمليه معينه
كالقصب واستهداف اهداف معينه لاخافه الناس
وبالتالي الزامهم على الذهاب الى على سبيل
المثال منطقه المواصي هذه احدى التفسيرات
زين العابدين يعني رفح الان بها غالبيه
شعب غزه غالبيه سكان غزه يعيشون في رفح
الان كيف سيكون شكل هذه المعركه ان
بدات
ايه المعركه ززين هي لن تكون مختلفه عن
غيرها ولكنها ليست بكثافه مدينه غزه وليست
بمساحه وكثافه ما يجري في خانيونس لانها
تعتبر من المناطق المهمه ومراكز الثقل
الاساسيه خان يونس اليوم قد لا يدخل الجيش
الاسرائيلي الى خانيونس يسعى الى التطويق
ومن ثم الذهاب
الى يعني الى رفع والهدف دائما هو او
العقبات هي العديد من الناس يعني اغلب 1.5
مليون نسمه من النازحين في هذه المنطقه
والخطوره الاكبر هي قربها من الحدود
المصريه وبالتالي مصر تخاف من تدفق
النازحين وبالتالي نقل المشكله الى مصر
وحتى حت موضوع الكوريدور فيلادلفيا هو
يتطلب موافقه مصريه لانتقاله الى قواعد
اشتباك وطريقه تشغيل معينه هذه كلها عقد
اساسيه ولكن
دائما نشكرك شكرا جزيلا العميد الياس حنا
من بيروت